[Music]
in unexpected reveal news submitted by
won't you be my neighbor a basketball
player was banned from playing after his
urine tests found him to be pregnant
what Oh does that happen
in Canada a lot can you stop with this
candidate I know
getting old fart I'm just curious it's a
different country out there no they piss
maple syrup okay
throwing next to the magnetic pole dude
there's all kind of [ __ ] happen after
exactly just just let them know like yes
I'm Canadian shut the [ __ ] up feel free
do you like hockey oh my god okay I like
Canada nice I guess that's a [ __ ]
knife huh
you guys driving the wrong side of the
road no I feel the same side can you
just stop answering my favorite
questions all right
so the basketball players name is DJ
Cooper he plays for the European
basketball circuit thing also doesn't
count
he now has been handed a two-year
suspension from FIBA coz she got
pregnant that's because he got pregnant
like how dare you get pregnant while
you're [ __ ] playing basketball pretty
much to the baby
is it good is the baby gonna come out of
the dick yeah okay so let me actually
just answer so what happened here is
that he used his girlfriend's urine and
they didn't know that she was pregnant
oh that's one of the pregnancy routines
I thought it was a transgender
basketball player this whole time I was
like okay let's really hear it look
he's passing so that's why he got
suspended for two years because he used
his girlfriend's oh it's because he was
smoking that weed and he doesn't want to
get in trouble I don't know what he was
our steroids he doesn't look like use of
steroids
it just started by oh that's true we
have like the same body that's what you
think you look like yep Wow Wow you
shouldn't even be an athlete Wow dude
you just got roasted some [ __ ] orbit
bro let me tell you something alright
real basketball players don't wear
t-shirts under their Jersey that's some
juice but he's practicing though he's
deflecting from the body I agree with it
I've never seen that before
yeah like practice games that's very
common that's not common okay I don't
know it to me look at that Jersey that
Jersey looks like a high school Jersey
or Maine high school juries are better
than that I played me that's lame
I can tell you that's not how they do in
practice his girlfriends I mean was he
like surprised in two different ways
like like oh [ __ ] surprise and then like
oh I don't know if that is the way that
they found out about the pregnancy I I
do know though is that they did not know
she was pregnant at the time of
submitting the urine so they were able
to find mmm this [ __ ] [ __ ] ruined
his career he passed you're right if it
didn't give away wasn't just praise if
she would have just [ __ ] it's his
fault
yeah he's not in there yeah but she
didn't take care of it that's what
that's what honestly pisses me off Wow
guys you could have closed her eye at
the last second her eye the vaginal or
you could wink yeah you know what the
guy busts you can the girl go and block
it pull it in and wink right now I think
you guys never did it before
cervical it's not a Kegel but a cervical
week it's like how you can wink your
butthole but servant
yeah the second layer of closing it
doesn't enter the you don't you [ __ ]
block that [ __ ] but now he has more time
with his girlfriend I would tell a kid
that [ __ ] he's jobless too though no job
okay she has a kid you got sick here I
heard they got really good welfare in
Europe find out mm-hmm so now he could
just be with his baby at home and a
government takes care of them and they
can play all day and not a down the road
yeah those 28 years old in case you guys
were wondering he played for AS Monaco
in Europe how crazy is it the typical um
you know the stereotype of like if I
have a kid it's gonna ruin my career
this guy literally [ __ ] because
they're having a kid at ruined his
career I don't think that's what it is I
think it's because he did something he
took some shitty substance that he's not
supposed to be take no no I know but
it's dads but that's what happened
that's what's that's what so it's still
his fault he the one that noted he's the
one that did some [ __ ] that couldn't see
me not on your if you use it on pay then
it would be his fault I can you somebody
else know it's her fault
no I think it's not his fault if only
that baby didn't admit it Stephen I just
hope that it's a boy because ever
because if it's not that's on her what
country are they from well he's from the
US so he came out of Ohio University on
your plays and he plays into European
weeks he plays for why man why would he
do something like that
they're probably drugs probably drugs
are people I know but like it's more of
at work
why are they even testing male urine for
pregnancy that's what I don't understand
that should've came out so it's like I
don't know how I'll [ __ ] pee test
goes like but it's like just in case
let's check this is [ __ ] urine for
pregnancy what they do yeah it's for
hormone so they do a hormone check to
see like where your test levels whatever
all the levels are if there's any
metabolites from any other peds and I
think having a female like hormone
that's produced by a female placenta
during pregnancy called HCG that's the
one that popped up I feel like why this
year yeah exactly you find this dude I
will never [ __ ] admit this [ __ ] if
you were I would start showing up to
practice showing a little bit I [ __ ]
told you guys is putting a little girl
up their titties nobody listen to me
that's true like show a little bit more
a little bit more and then I'm [ __ ]
eight months pregnant and I'm like oh my
god I did model that pretend she was
transgender
remember came out like a week later like
actually I'm not sorry but in your
scenario you still can't play yeah but
at least yeah yeah damn team getting
paid what if I get all [ __ ] to
see he's holding the belly while still
Dunkin he could still done cuz it is a
pillow or something and then you become
like you're then you become a celebrity
because I oh my God look at him he's so
strong do or you not only is he pregnant
but he's an athlete while pregnant
you're get on the cover of ESPN Magazine
yeah I love like your world works the
way it really happen is they would
probably like take you to some
government dungeon and start testing on
your ass oh [ __ ] I'm thinking that I was
gonna say you get a guy who does special
effects makeup and then you're like oh
[ __ ] and your water breaks while you're
on the court oh did you have like like a
[ __ ] latex baby could I hit the
ground with a [ __ ] umbilical cord and
[ __ ] and you're like I told you guys to
grow a couple inches because it's on the
it's the umbilical cords it was right
yeah we're delicate and II can get a
robotic baby to [ __ ] push that baby
out all the DoubleDown on your life I
love me and you could use deep fakes and
[ __ ] and all that and have a [ __ ]
double life I'm gonna Instagram with
your baby on it yeah like see this is
how big
would be a real baby though because the
girlfriend is having the baby
you have to have twins though because if
your girlfriend's pregnant the same time
and people know then it's like oh we're
having twins
yeah robot baby yeah one was a robot
baby from him and then ones from her and
it's like we have twins it doesn't need
to be twins
it needs to be one baby no but they came
out at the same time in there and
they're pregnant at the same because
they saw you give birth on the court
yeah his wife had a baby at the same
time he [ __ ] popped out a baby at the
core so we share the same DNA yeah yeah
yeah twins yeah yeah okay so DJ Cooper
announced that he was leaving a s Minako
in this last September and so he cited
family reasons at that time but then
recently we found out about this whole
pregnancy thing because he got banned on
the spot when he was trying to apply for
the national basketball team of Bosnia
as a naturalized player cuz he applied
for citizenship back in 2014
why would you want to do that no so he
was a huge playing for Ohio State
he didn't make NBA obviously nobody's
interested so then he has to prove
himself in other leagues in order to try
to get a shot at the NBA or to just make
a living yeah and that's why why he's
taking steroids and [ __ ] cuz he wants to
get better cuz he feels the pressure
having not been drafted yeah with a body
like mine you can't be an athlete buddy
so you trying to keep it going
that's [ __ ] positivity over there we
can all learn from Joe could be a bowler
how's that positive like no I'm looking
I'm pumped I'm I'm just like saying like
if me me and him are the same and he
said it's pretty positive though
nobody's not doing anything I'm not
saying I'm Kobe no the fact that you see
yourself yeah body he looks good
no he's a loser it's what I'm saying
maybe the decisions are but I'm saying
he looks like an athlete but join one
that he's a loser and so now he looks
nothing like Joe yep he looks good he
looks like a basketball player
see I see that man and I go you got a
lot of work to do buddy but that you say
you look like you that's what I'm saying
I got a lot of work to do oh I see
myself in here man I go mmm that's why
you're not in the NBA and you're never
gonna be like Kobe
not cuz you piss it not not because you
let your wife piss in the cup it's
because you look like me
and I will never be in the NBA tada
you get my drift hundred percent okay
clear as day
and it's funny that he chose Bosnia of
all places yeah I'm curious why you
chose probably has hookups well those
guys they just go like so one of our
buddies like David's buddy Khalif he
played in South America I think my
Argentina or something as a pro
basketball player so it's just wherever
you have hookups and I think he was in
like the NBA Development League at the
time and he was just really wanted to
play pro basketball so they just kind of
apply everywhere and and they go through
the steps become a naturalized citizens
they can play cuz if that's really your
passion and you just want to play
anywhere dude NFL it's the same [ __ ] and
but and now they have the XFL coming
back yeah just Vince McMahon's League
and so there's even more of an
opportunity for the washout guys who
don't make NFL like to have a minute
they do NFL outside of the US yeah yeah
they have they have a European League
and/or they have a another have a
Canadian League All American football
yeah football but it's not NFL it's like
another like a minor league I didn't
know they played football Tim Tebow
played there for a little bit
Wow Sports is interesting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you